nous voyons des indications qui montrent
que l'armée russe veut étendre le pont
terrestre vers la transnistrie et bien
que les forces russes puissent être
capables d'atteindre la plupart de leurs
objectifs dans les mois à venir nous
pensons qu'elles ne seront pas en mesure
d'étendre leur contrôle jusqu'à odessa
et jusqu'à la transnistrie sans lancer
une certaine forme de mobilisation et il
est de plus en plus improbable que les
russes puissent s'emparer dans les
semaines à venir des zones qu'il
souhaite contrôler mais putin juge très
probablement que la russie a une plus
grande capacité que ses adversaires à
supporter les défis ils misent
probablement sur l'affaiblissement des
états unis et de l'europe face aux
pénuries alimentaires et à la hausse des
prix de l'énergie
en attendant audi